there's a really interesting debate
happening within my audience within you
fine folks and the debate is
is it better or worse
if republicans
right wingers trumpists marjorie taylor
greene mike lindell and others is it
better or worse
if they really believe trump's lies and
the lies being told by republicans about
the 2020 election or whatever
or if they don't believe them but repeat
them anyway which is worse in terms of
what it means about them as people about
the american political landscape about
humanity quite frankly and the jumping
off point for this debate was actually
the story that i did yesterday where we
uh talked about a text message that was
leaked from my pillow ceo mike lindell
to donald trump's former chief of staff
mark meadows the text messages from
shortly after the 2020 election and it's
a very long the text message is almost
as long as one of those cvs receipts you
know six seven feet long and in the text
message mike lindell at least appears to
really believe trump won he's got the
evidence he's got the machines he's got
all the different stuff and he texts
mark meadows and says we've got to keep
fighting and let's do this and let's do
that so at least apparently it seemed to
be sort of like the proof we were
looking for to tell us that mike pillow
is not just saying this stuff he
genuinely sincerely deeply believes it
and the video got close to a hundred
thousand views in the first few hours
and it's a story of great interest to
many of you
there's basically two perspectives here
one view is
this text message proves that mike
pillow
really believes it and that this makes
him to quote one of our viewers less
psychotic
because if it were true that trump
really won the election if and it were
stolen right imagine that it were true
that biden stole it from trump if it
were true
it would be logical that if you care
about democracy you would be doing
everything you can to get the word out
you would be spending if you're mike
pillow and you have the money
you'd be spending your money to try to
prove
that indeed it was stolen and to try to
overturn it in other words
if pillow and others
didn't really believe the election was
stolen but they were out there saying it
anyway they would be truly depraved and
dishonest whereas if they really believe
it but they're wrong
they're just wrong they're less nutty in
a sense that's one perspective that
people in the audience had
now the problem with
really believing it is that it's
absolutely horrifying that people could
fall for something so obviously untrue
so it's disturbing and it's dystopian
but in a different way now there's
another perspective
and that perspective came through in
some of the responses i got
which is even though mike pillow did
text this to mark meadows
it really still doesn't prove that
pillow is a believer and the idea there
was
pillow was knowingly planting stuff so
that later if it came out it would look
like he was a true believer i actually
find that sort of hard to believe to be
honest having spoken to and interviewed
mike pillow on the show and we've been
observing him now for you know a couple
years since the start of the pandemic
it's i just don't think that that's how
he operates but it's theoretically
possible it's completely speculative now
there's another set of people who are
focusing on the money that pillow spent
as kind of the proof and it's true that
he has spent a bunch of money pushing
all of these different challenges and
getting voting machines and paying i.t
people and all of this stuff and for
what why has he been spending all of
that money
a supposedly sane person
might spend you know you spend your
first hundred grand on this nonsense
and then you realize this isn't going to
work to put trump back in office trump's
now been out of office for closer to two
years i'm gonna give up the spending and
every single week he's making some
promise he obviously can't keep and so
he must be a true believer because no
reasonable person would keep
hemorrhaging money for something that's
obviously going nowhere there's no
reward in sight it makes no sense he
must believe it and just be out of his
gourd
another reaction was well you know with
mike pillow you've got to consider his
history of addiction it's widely known
he had serious drug addiction issues and
a few of you wrote to me saying you
probably have
based on what we know about his drug
addiction he probably has a generally
addictive personality and addictive
personalities thrive on positive
feedback loops and pillow is getting
enough positive reaction he goes to
these trump rallies and he says we're
about to do it we're suing all machines
or we're about to file
uh you know uh a preliminary adjunction
as he likes to say a preliminary
injunction and everybody cheers and that
might be the addictive personality
positive feedback loop that keeps him
going independently of whether he
believes it or not he says it and the
crowd cheers and it's like you got a
jackpot on a slot machine for a gambling
addict okay that's an interesting idea
but let's step back a little bit
the topic of a true believer and a false
believer in the context of cults
this is a cult
has been actually studied academically
cult experts and others
who are the more more dangerous ones are
the true believers more dangerous or are
the false believers more dangerous and
the con concept is basically as follows
with any cult-like movement
you have some false believers and what
we mean by a false believer is someone
who declares their commitment to the
ideology or to the leader or to whatever
they declare their ideology in order to
have membership and that's it they don't
they don't believe it any further than
that that's one those are the false
believers you then have the true
believers who genuinely believe this
stuff and you can look at any cult and
you find examples of this you look at
the jim jones people's temple there were
people who were very very borderline
they didn't really believe this stuff
literally but they kind of wanted to be
part of the group so we see that in just
about every cult and there's also the
other side of it which is do the leaders
prefer true or false believers in the
case of trumpism which is what we're
talking about
the false believers have basically been
welcomed we know
there are tons of republicans who are
and have been anti-trump privately we
found out after the fact usually but as
long as they profess their allegiance
and keep their mouth shut trump and
others in the upper echelon seem
basically fine with it now of course as
soon as it's known that they don't
really believe you get kicked out you
get attacked you get excoriated but
that's a different story so there's a
term called true believer syndrome and
it has a specific meaning this was
coined by lamar keane
and true believers are people who
continue to believe in a paranormal
event or a phenomenon or something that
took place
even after it's been proven to have been
staged or untrue now at this point in
the real world not in nutty wherever but
in the real factual empirical world
we could almost call
we could call
the claim that trump actually won in
2020 it's now like it's it's now a
paranormal belief it's a false event it
didn't really happen we know it we know
that that's not true
and hilariously
keen considered
true believer syndrome to be a cognitive
disorder and we could debate whether
that's the case or not so at the end of
the day i don't have the answer as to
whether the true believers or the false
believers are more dangerous we've said
of the people who continue to claim
trump won
some literally believe it and some say
it to show allegiance to the group
and i don't know who's more dangerous i
want to hear from you you tell me
which group do you think poses more of a
threat one of our sponsors is blinkist
who's been supporting the david pakman
show longer than any other sponsor
blinkist is the app that lets you listen
to or read an entire non-fiction book in
just 15 minutes blinkist is the way to
absorb those books you can't make time
for blinkist takes top non-fiction
titles pulls out the book's key
takeaways and insights and gives it to
you in the form of a text or audio
explainer that you can consume in 15
minutes with blinkist now you actually
do have time to learn about all the
things you've been wanting to tackle on
the blinkist app i just listened to this
is your mind on plants by the great
michael pollan
super interesting the history of
caffeine and so many other things
blinkist has you covered on podcast 2.
blinkist takes long episodes of popular
podcasts and distills them into audio
you can listen to in 15 minutes with
blinkist you can become knowledgeable
about so many different things you can
have conversations with people about
more topics blinkist makes you more
well-rounded
try blink is for free and get 25 off a
subscription go to blinkist.com
pacman the link is down below